now this is eight news now live at six
live local now in two days federal
unemployment benefits for more than 115
000 people will be coming to an end good
evening to you thank you for joining us
at six i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez so those benefits that we're
talking about are the extra weekly 300
dollar payments and the pua payments joe
mohler is live outside of the deter
offices to break it down for us joe
as both of you know these federal
benefits have been helping thousands
throughout the pandemic and now that
they're coming to an end in just a few
days some business owners are hoping
that more people will now join the
workforce
the 300 boost is coming to an end when
the pandemic started the federal
government implemented extra benefits
for people who lost their jobs that
included extra weekly pay and benefits
for gig workers or independent
contractors called pua the gateworking
side that program is coming to a
complete and utter halt which means that
there will be no more collecting
benefits hansen runs a popular pool help
facebook group this week dieter reminded
the claimants the extra federal benefits
are ending september 4th they're in an
appeal status still be able to go
through that process and if their appeal
is successful then yes of course they
will be paid the federal boost has been
a controversial topic as employers
across the valley and nations struggle
to find workers not yet
nothing's changed as of today lola
pokorny owns lola's louisiana kitchen in
summerlin she says hiring has not been
easy and hopes maybe benefits ending may
attract more workers we've been in this
kind of stalled stage of recovery for a
very long time which has caused so many
supply
chain voids and
it's not easy to run a company right now
as the pandemic continues hanson says it
isn't only the benefits that has stopped
people from heading back to work she
says some are worried about issues like
the delta variant child care and finding
the right wage we have to really have to
really cognizantly come to the table and
kind of you know meet
you know somewhere in the middle
by way of either raising wages or
offering or incentivizing
you know employment you know conditions
of employment for individuals to make it
worth their while
now back out here live this all ends on
september 4th which means this is the
last week of these benefits so people
will file on sunday in their last
payment with these extra federal
benefits will be next week reporting
live outside the dealer office joe
mohler 8 news now